comme chaque matin jean christophe
brondy prépare le repas des 600 élèves
du collège apollinaire de plaisir mais
chaque dimanche les repas sont destinés
à d'autres gourmet le centre hospitalier
de versailles les pompiers de nos repas
et de louveciennes une initiative débuté
en mars est toujours en cours j'ai des
amis qui sont dans la profession
médicale et je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage que ça s'arrête d'un coup parce
que voilà ces gens vous un vrai confort
le plus de possibles et la brousse
chance que j'ai c'est que ma directrice
de collège et les autorisations de ces
niveaux ont été données pour que je
puisse utiliser de toujours pour
fabriquer justement c'est dire pas ce
sont 700 repas qui sont préparées par
jean christophe et son équipe grâce au
partenariat de fournisseurs artisans et
grandes surfaces
en mai dernier les pattes de la
fondation béland à magnanville recevait
deux semblent ou jetable pour son
personnel du matériel créé par des
couturières amateurs du collectif blues
pour l'hôpital
une initiative arrêtés fin juin qui tend
aujourd'hui à se professionnaliser
on a clairement eu pendant le parti
bénévoles des couturières qui disait
mais non je suis en train de piquer le
boulot a dégradé couturière
professionnelle
donc ça ne va pas et la notion de dire
si on va on va monter quelque chose
autour des couturières professionnels à
l'origine c'est une demande de bénévoles
dans lequel il ya aussi des propos
aujourd'hui organisés en tant que guide
les métiers de l'éguille rassemble une
quarantaine de couturière
professionnelle lancée pendant le
confinement le collectif a distribué
plus de 55000 blues dans trois
départements dont les yvelines